hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast back to basics
fundamental concepts and special
considerations in RNA isolation
presented by mr. Abhishek Sharma a
senior global market manager at Keoghan
i'm susie valdez of lab routes and all
be your moderator for today's events
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaya Jen kaya Jen
serves more than 500,000 customers
around the globe all seeking insights
from the building blocks of life DNA RNA
and proteins they deliver samples to
insight solutions for molecular testing
propelling hygiene customers from start
to finish to unlock new insights before
word again I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located at
the lower left of your presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appear on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you'll be viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or use the
Q&A button and let us know you're having
a problem good news
the presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing educational credits
click on that button in the bottom left
hand corner and follow the process for
obtaining your credits without further
ado please join me in welcoming mr. Nava
Shaikh Sharma I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
thank you and thank you for giving me
this opportunity to talk about the
sometimes not so taken seriously facts
of RNA isolation so hello everyone my
name is Abhishek Sharma and as I it was
already introduced that I am the senior
global market manager for sample
technologies at Kaizen I'm I've been
working here for more than five years
and respond
to to do watch the the RNA related
technologies very closely in this domain
so I would be very happy to share some
of my experience in the lab before when
I was a biochemist and today when I'm
working with kaijin so before I move
forward and share with you the agenda I
would like to make sure that you to
manage your expectations that today's
webinar has the name suggest we want to
go back to the basics of RNA isolation
why because I think that's the step one
in any of your research applications
that you want to do downstream and
sometimes we miss out on some of the
small considerations that are needed to
get that high yield as well as the RNA
integrity just a legal disclaimer that
whatever products that I would be
talking here today and the techniques I
will be talking about are only intended
for molecular biology applications and
they have no claims or no intention for
diagnosis or prevention of treatment of
disease purpose if you want to see all
the updated licensing related to our
products you can go on - dot-com and
download the handbooks and user manuals
or you can always reach out to your
technical services or your local
distributor in your country so as I said
this is the agenda for today's talk I'll
just touch a little bit let's brush up
on knowledge about the what I call the
RNA universe inside the cell then I give
certain general remarks related to
handling the RNA in general whether it's
pre isolation during the isolation or
post isolation we talk about the
stabilization of RNA in samples before
actual process then the special
considerations for different sample
types in RNA isolation I would touch a
little bit about micro RNA and EXO
some'll rnase purification and then at
the end I would like to share some of
the tides and solutions for quality RNA
and yes with that
this is the view of which is from our
RNA universe app so and why we call it
our any universe because you can there
are it's it's nice overview to show you
that there are so many types of RNAs and
when we started looking at RNAs
formally the focus of RNA was always on
the longer than 200 nucleotide which we
call also as the mRNA or ribosomal I'd
on RNA ironically we used to call them
the total RNA but but when the studies
expanded we started seeing the roles of
other type of smaller RNAs for example
as the small non-coding micro RNAs or
now in fact the long non-coding RNAs
these are functional RNAs molecules we
know that do not translate into proteins
but they are often involved in this
regulation of the gene expression and
and very important when you're doing
studying a pathway or or how a diseased
area works with time people have also
started exploring more further than that
and we call the new stream the hexa
Somel RNAs and the RNAs which are
produced present in the extracellular
vesicles I would not go into much
details there because that's in itself
it's a very big topic and so I'll keep
it very basic as I said if you want to
get the complete picture you can always
download this RNA universe app by going
on the chitin common to the app section
it's very interactive you can you can
plug and play and then and and look at
the different RNAs and and by the way on
the left side I mentioned like did you
know that people who do RNA research
there have been more than 30 scientists
who have received a Nobel Prize for
research in RNA so I think that's that's
that's really a proud thing now how the
RNA is distributed in in a in a typical
cell a difficult growing mammalian cell
culture can contain from ten to thirty
picogram total RNA per cell whereas a
fully differentiated primary cell will
contain far less like in the region of
less than 1 picogram per cell
the majority of RNA molecules are tRNAs
or rrnas messenger RNA which people are
mostly interested in only accounts for
one to five percent even when you look
further into the messenger RNA it it
comprises of three percent pool and if
you if you look at the classification
based on as abundance which is which is
shown at the the lowest table
it can even be less than 0.01% that's
rare and low abundance messages so which
can even just translate into a copy
number of only five to fifteen molecules
per cells so so what it says that it
it's really important that how you
handle your har in a while your
isolation process because it's it's
definitely it's it's it's not that much
that you can afford to lose any amount
of RNA here I just wanted to share with
you that how a typical or a generic gene
expression workflow looks like no matter
what you do downstream whether you're
using NGS whether you're using the the
qpcr pcr techniques but that's how a
generic process looks like so it starts
with sample collection which can happen
in the field or in the lab or in some
other lab where you get your samples
from then you do the disruption to get
open it up these cells orbit issues then
you do the actual purification get your
nucleic acid out then you do the cDNA
synthesis and analysis with a depending
on what what technique are you using and
further you do a data interpretation and
an analysis and of your experiment I
would only focus on the first three
parts because we will be going to talk
about the isolation only but I think
sample collection and disruption is an
integral part of that
so some general remarks on on handling
the RNA you should always wear latex or
vinayak loves to prevent any rnas
contamination and as we know that RNA is
a is very stable and it does not require
any cofactors and are effective in very
small quantities also so we need to make
sure that we minimize the rnas
contamination as much as possible this
can come from any source it could be
your human skin it could be dust
particles which can carry bacteria or
molds and we know that RNA is relatively
unstable as compared to the to the DNA
and it can break down very quickly with
the with the RNA so make sure that you
wear the gloves which prevent the
contamination you should keep changing
your gloves very frequently you should
stay with the recommended processes if
you're using a plastic wear if you're
using a non disposable plastic wear make
sure that you treat it well with the RNA
so that it's rnase free you have to
rinse it with any wedge your editor
followed by a rnase free water
alternatively you can always use
chloroform resistant plastic wears that
can be rinsed with chloroform but make
sure that you use you you know that
you're using a chloroform resistant
plastic wear so of course all these
things can be done but at the same time
working quickly with your samples and
video with your RNA carefully is the key
for for a good success during the
experiment further I am trying to talk
here about also what can you do if
you're using it last where you should
clean them with detergent you should
rinse them i one baked at 240 degrees
for at least four hours before use
because autoclaving alone will not fully
inactivate the RNA so alternative
treatments could be with depc
treatment if you when you're doing the
analysis afterwards if you're running
the electrophoresis the tank should be
clean with it
they should be totally dense without any
free water and then with ethanol and
then allow them to dry up if you're
using plastic in the indy like for it
clanks so they're not resistant to
ethanol so you should be careful about
that fact also if you want to look at
the complete tips they're also as I said
available in the resources on the
section there is this link provided here
but where you can always ask for the
link later on now I would like to move
to the next step during the process
which we call as the excuse me
stabilization of the RNA in the samples
why it is important like and it might be
possible that you might not be
harvesting these samples by yourself it
might be happening somewhere else but if
you're doing that by ourselves we have I
think it's important to know that once
you harvest the sample there could be
two type of artifacts that can can
happen depending on how you are handling
your sample if they could be
down-regulation which is basically the
genes and the the genes get down
regulated and the enzymatic degradation
of RNA which results in artificial
reduction of both of nonspecific or
specific messenger rnas so basically
whatever the messenger RNA level was in
vivo is down regulated and it's not
showing the same during the later on
when you're doing the isolation so at
the same time it can happen that with
stress or environmental conditions or
processing of the sample certain genes
can be induced and this will increase in
the level of messenger RNAs so therefore
the combination of these two effects can
have can have very very entry's also
near the transcription profile which
would be probably completely different
from the true in vivo gene expression
patterns and you might wonder that why
certain
data is not coming correctly so you need
to need to consider this that the sample
collection and stabilization is is very
important normally to stabilize the
samples traditionally people harvest
these am the these samples and
immediately froze them in liquid
nitrogen and store at minus 80 degrees
until it is processed its engine and
generally it works but at the same time
there are many stabilisation reagents
which are available from commercial
suppliers like Kaizen which can be
alternatively used to stabilize RNA and
you can actually stabilize the RNA to be
used for many many much much longer time
well in the in this particular slide
what this is what I just spoke about
we're just trying to visualize that that
one rat kidney was either immediately
stabilized in using an RNA later reagent
or when it was left on stabilized so
what we did we after every four five
minutes cap
RNA was purified with the stabilized
sample using a RNA easy Kett and the N
and from the unstabilized samples using
a standard procedure then what we did
the purified RNA was analyzed on an
agarose gel and the gap pH expression
was examined by northern blot so you can
clearly see that just after five ten
minutes that you starts having a smear
so that shows that the RNA start
degrading very fast within like 10
minutes and but on the other side
destabilized RNA was intact and you
could get clear bands even at after 60
minutes excuse me as I mentioned that
normally the goal of stabilization is to
stop induction of any RNA transcription
it prevents any down regulation it
prevents any unspecific degradation of
RNA so I think it's important to see
that what are the various type of stable
agents available there are agents which
bind directly to the nucleic acids there
are agent that lies these cells there
agents that inhabit denature or or to
the precipitation of the nucleases Titan
also has variety of of stabilization
reagents depending on different sample
types which is shown here in the in the
table below so you have different sample
types then you have different sample
stabilization and at the same time the
if you want to do a simultaneous sample
stabilization and purification so there
are different kits available for that
well now moving to the next step which
is disruption so I would say the
effective disruption and homogenize
ation for any sample is absolute
requirement for all RNA isolation
purification procedures normally there
are two two steps involved in that in
that disruption and homogenization the
first part which is about completely
disrupting the structure of the cell
tissue walls and then basically the
purpose is to release all the RNA
content in the sample in the environment
and there are different methods to do
depending on your samples and in
complete disruption can have
significantly it can really reduce your
your heals
then what you do you do a homogeneous
ation which is necessary because you
want to reduce the viscosity which
happens because when you when you
disrupt there a different type of genome
a DNA or proteins or other biomolecules
available so you would like to reduce
that viscosity and if you don't do it
properly then you can have inefficient
binding of RNA and therefore later you
can really also reduce the the yields
like that so classical method which I
think everyone knows is the using the
motor and and baesell
you just use a liquid nitrogen to freeze
your sample then you make a powder
this approach works well but it's still
incomplete then you use the powder
sample you resuspend it into a cow
traffic lysis buffer to do the further
lysis and then you share the the genomic
DNA with the needle and syringe which
improves the efficiency and it also
helps in removing the genomic DNA but it
it's not always a hundred percent
reproducible the same results it doesn't
work always because G DNA can always add
viscosity and you can have clogging of
your filters you can have like a bit
let's say even a failed isolation
procedure this is just to show a very
fast and simple homogenization kit for
cell lysate we call it the gaia shredder
it's a good option for a convenient
homogenize ation if it offers very fast
and simple methods here and here also
you can see the comparison of method and
their their effectiveness so again the
same gap ph plot with non bloating when
you will have and you did not use
homogenization when you just use
vortexing and when you use a shredder or
any electric homogenize or so it gives
if you're using a cell lysate it gives
pretty good results that you don't even
need to go for an electric homogenizer
excuse me now with time there have been
many mechanical tools on the market
developed to help you out with
disruption and homogenization steps
these tools accomplish both disruption
and homogenization simultaneously it
does require bead mills
it could be stainless steel or glass
beads depending on the tissue or the
sample type gaijin provides series of
such methods depending on your
throughput so if you just want to run as
simple as a one sample polar run you
should use a tissue rupture if you want
to go up to twelve samples per run the
tissue we call it the tissue eliezer
low throughput and it has a bigger range
it can work with the east bacteria
humans plan
and if you really are doing high
throughput or mid throughput activities
then visualizer 2 would be your best
deal I have to say and it's it these are
very benchtop compact instruments but
that really provides a good efficient
simultaneous disruption and
homogenization of your samples I think
that's a good example to show that how
effective tissue disruption is when so
in this and the what are the benefits of
using a mechanical method so what what
was done here was that the various rat
tissues whether it was skin hurt lung
brain they were disrupted either using
visualize at low throughput or taste
like visualizer too and then the RNA was
purified using a chi cube and then we
used a spectrophotometer to to look at
the yields of the RNA what you can
clearly see is that the data illustrates
that there's a consistency that you can
achieve with these mechanical methods
and that's important for your
reproducibility of your results which is
I think a very big concern always ok so
that was about the disruption now I'll
switch the gears a bit into the next
step so once you have done the
disruption homogenization a good life
solution is ready then let's talk about
some tips and tricks in in isolating RNA
from different type of samples of course
we would not go into details of every
sample type but you can always send us
questions or ask the questions if you
have any specific question for your
protocols but yeah as first let let's
have a quick look at the - I would say
the two main techniques or technologies
available to do the isolation that's
precipitation versus the spin columns so
precipitation is all of us know it's we
all have used in home as home brew
methods with phenyl chloroform
precipitator isolation it's cheap
it is required it's very scalable as
compared to spin column that it has a
higher material cost but but then I
think we should look at some of the
other pros and cons of both the
techniques that in the beginning it
might look that spin columns are
costlier but then precipitation has
longer handling time incubation times
you need several rounds to even get a
decent purity there's always a risk of
losing your RNA pellet it's so much
dependent on piping skills and
especially like if you have small
samples you cannot afford to lose any
any of your pellets there on the other
side spin column is fast it's easy to
use you get high form of purity as well
as the integrity is maintained it is
coming in different types and sizes for
even very small sample so the
reproducibility of your of your results
like has much higher chance here and
yeah so now moving on as I mentioned
like this is just to show you how do you
deal with the isolating RNA when which I
call the difficult to lyse tissues like
hurt muscles and other fibrous tissues
there's always a challenge with the
contractile proteins tissues collagen
which can interfere with your isolation
process so you really need to make sure
that you treat it with a protein protein
k or RN is free protein K and protease
and phenol containing licensed reagents
because that's an important step to make
to maintain you know your proper
conditions and that do not degrade of
your RNA and then after that I think you
should make sure that you use a a good
we call an entire dynasty hardening easy
tissue kids but you should use a good K
to make sure to get that a good yield at
the end from these difficult Elias
tissues in this example is just showing
you that how a quality PCR was performed
with a total RNA which was which was
isolated with help of our and easy
fibrous tissue
and then you can see that consistency in
the Hindi in the graph and in the in the
in the signal that was received RNA from
FFP I think SSP is one a challenging
sample in itself we all mostly people
who are working with with SSP know that
there are two reasons first is that RNA
gets physically fragmented when which is
mainly the function of how the long
blocks or sections have been stored
usually at room temperature I think
second there of the formaldehyde reacts
with the amino and groups of nucleic
acid or proteins resulting in these
covalent chemical modifications and
cross linkage happens
so there are FFP kits which uses protein
kinase to digest away the proteins which
allows like the RNA or DNA gets soluble
eyes but what it does not do it it does
not break up the cross-linking so we
have made these special more advanced
FFPE kits that includes a specialized
buffer which is effective enough to do
the traversing of the cross-linking
which is I think important to make sure
that you you get all the yield back when
you're working with the FFPE samples as
I say that all of these are a topic in
itself so if you want to do more details
about a complete guide of SFP then you
should look check out this this brochure
it's called critical factors for
molecular analysis of FFP samples this
is a
example to show you that how we did a
successful detection of micro RNA and
mRNA from the same aleut using a micro
RNA EC FFPE kit and it shows that how
purified RNA was at even had was
formerly in fixed for 24 hours and 60
hours and then still you can see the
that the C key value you can see the in
the yields were very high if you're
working with human blood samples there
could be many challenges right from
small amount of RNA the RNA integrity
could be issue due to the presence of
RNAs in the blood there are different
type of there is cellular RNA there's
EXO so mälaren a free circulating RNA in
and contaminations we have you have to
make sure that all the contaminations
are properly removed such as
anticoagulants used in stabilization
sample so if you so you have to make
sure that the decontamination these in I
think that's the take-home message for
me from this this this slide that makes
sure that you they if you remove these
anticoagulants right in time from from
during your your isolation process there
there are these special special range of
products which which kaijin also
provides in combination with another
company
it's called pax gene I think that's an
efficient and effective all right from
the collection tubes to isolation so
please do check out if you want to know
more details about that on the vaccine
website then I'm pretty sure that a lot
of people who work with the plan
material and I can isolate regularly the
the nucleic acids there and they know
that the pain there because initially it
looks like that the sample abundance is
not the problem but then you have
other problems like plant metabolites
are difficult to remove so what we
recommend is use as healthy young
tissues recommended from our site
because they have fewer metabolites than
the same amount of the older tissues
there are many homemade protocols which
are recommended for example you should
be growing plants in darkness for one or
two days before you do the harvesting to
prevent any high level of plant
metabolites and of course you shouldn't
there are also commercial solutions
available like there are dedicated kids
which can solve all your worries at one
go and kaijin has specially designed
this problem of overcoming the
metabolite challenges with the help of
the gaijin' are an easy plant kits and I
think on the next slide yes I would like
to show you that how you can get
reproducible purification HOF and the
intact RNA from different type of issues
by using just this one one kit I mean
here you can see there are five
different plant species and the rnaseq
plant many was used to purify the RNA
and then the results were run on the
agarose gel and you can see the sharp
intense ribosomal RNA bands which which
indicates the reproducibility of the
intact RNA
than just few thoughts on isolating RNA
from bacteria and virus again it can be
challenging because bacterial mRNA has
no 5 - gap and it only rarely has any
poly a tail so the hybrid capture is
almost impossible for from a messenger
RNA there we have a specific specialized
gate for that which is called are an
easy protect bacteria Kate I think
that's that's the that's a good solution
as compared to any home brew method that
you can use for - when if you're working
with bacterias and also the same goes
for the for the viral viral RNA when
you're purifying it then the major
challenge comes is that it it's so small
and and so concentrate that has compared
to the in there is a large enlarge
sample volume of the whole store or the
sample that you use so when you're
dealing with such huge volumes I think
the range of Khayyam viral gates which
can help you to get starting volumes of
as high as 5 ml would be would be
definitely helpful and in this example
what we're trying to to show is the
amplification of RNA from plasma the RNA
in this case was extracted using a
Khayyam viral RNA kit and the products
of 1026 nucleotide RNA fragments were
spiked and and you are then able to see
that that RNA was extracted even when
present in low copy number so I think
copy number somewhere around plus 100
something so
then the next step which I think I
wanted to spend some time with you was
about removal of the genomic DNA so so
why genomic DNA removal in itself it's
very important that if you if you're
left with traces of amounts of GTN a and
then you do sensitive applications for
example or if you run real-time rt-pcr
both RNA and DNA targets will get
amplified and you might get unreliable
quantification and results which you
were not intended in the beginning they
can interfere with the primer designs
they can so I think it's important that
you should already start thinking of an
to make sure that the genomic DNA is
completely anime eliminated even during
the RNA purification process and you can
always check back and and do it again
during the cDNA synthesis process just
to make sure that you're you can you can
get rid of as much as soft eg DNA what
gaijin has or offers is different types
depending on on the needs of the
experiment so either you can you can
have the dnase digestion after the
isolation process or what you can do is
you can do it during with help of the
eliminated columns which comes without
an easy plan scale so you can use the
Eliminator solution which comes with
plus universal kids and I think it'll go
a little bit more details about that in
the coming slides as I mentioned that
how it can really interfere with your
with the spikes and and and having wrong
data at the end you can see that when
you used the Kaizen and you had the
amplification plot and when you use the
supplier some other supplier you had
this additional amplification during the
cycling
ok so I think this is a particular in
particular a little bit crowded slide I
didn't know how I could I could put that
but this was just this the whole
take-home messages to show you that for
every sample type and every need there
is a specific kit available from chitin
because of our of our quality which is
which we provide with or with our kids
and then you can also choose you the
capacity that you would like you'd want
to specifically have for your for for
your for you for your particular needs
or particular sample types gaijin has
these new I think more many people are
aware about the are n easy kids but we
have these are in easy plus kits which
have the same procedure of bind washing
allude but you can as I mentioned before
you can do the genomic DNA during that
process so they are an easy plus can
it's having an Eliminator spin column
which is so ii like after once during
you have done the license and
homogenization you do the on column
genomic DNA digestion before moving for
further and getting your total RNA with
the are in ez plus universal kits you
also do the you use at the second step
use did you know make DNA eliminate a
solution to get to make sure that you
are free of the GT na a little bit about
the micro RNA easy it's very quickly
growing field in the research and
they're normally the micro rna's are
class of an endogenous
naturally-occurring 18 to 24 nucleotide
non-coding RNAs that they mediate the
the post transcriptional gene regulation
due to their short length they usually
require specialized isolation and
analysis protocol so Kaizen has the
skies and micro are an easy range of
kids which uses kiya soul as part of it
so when using phenol based purification
with try reagent you eliminate any
phenol carryover by using the spin
column technology
instead of using the phase separation
method so basically the thing that the
messages that you do not have any phenol
carryover and a highly pure RNA if you
use this technique and here it is shown
also when the OD values were taken that
phenol which absorbs at 270 you can see
if the micro are any easy which is in
blue line was used and if the trial was
used exosome isolation it's becoming a
again a an interesting field where
people in liquid biopsies they want to
isolate exosomes they want to categorize
them at the same time people also want
to go further and they want to look at
the the RNAs which are present inside
the exosomes so with with one of our
partners exosome Diagnostics Kaizen has
has gone for two type of kits one as XOR
any easy which you can specifically use
to get micro rna's sorry the RNA
isolation or Malhar any isolation and
then you have eggs so easy just if you
want to do the characterization and just
want to have the eggs or zomes there are
we have a series of special exosome
webinars available for this topic
because it's a new upcoming technology
how it is compared with the let's say
the gold standard ultra centrifugation
so I think that should be interesting
for only for people who really want to
are doing in something in that direction
now the last part of of today's webinar
I wanted to show you some of the tools
from Teijin for example I like really
this one this is a we call it the RNA
selection be linked this is available
online on if you go on vacation comm
what it helps you is that all the
different solutions that I shared with
you during the presentation you can
actually go you can click on on your
sample type and then you can choose the
right quantity you can choose whether
you're looking for hot na whether you're
looking for RNA including micro RNA
whether you're looking for
do you know make DNA removal EXO
Somalian EXO Somel RNA and then it shows
you the right product and you just have
to click on that and it takes you
directly to the product page also we
have developed with time and we we call
it the RNA Resource Center we before had
like all the information was like in
bits and pieces but in last five years
since I've also been here we have put
all that together into a resource
centers if you go there you can get the
RNA web app that I showed you right in
the beginning there are videos there
also these videos are also available on
youtube if you would like to search we
call them the troubleshooting guide like
five common problems in RNA isolation
and the easy solution for that they are
an easy you can download some of the
white papers you can go further if you
are interested in the exosomes and here
you can you can also know more about the
micro RNA and then you can we have these
all these tips and tricks available as
posters so you can download these
posters depending on your sample type
well yeah thank you for your attention
and with that I'm almost at the end of
my presentation I hope it was helpful
and I'm open for any questions as well
thank you so much of a shape for that
informative presentation will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started we have a great
audience today and we'll start with
question number one what can I use to
isolate RNA smaller than 200 nucleotides
okay
so I think as I mentioned that normally
anything which is below 200 nucleotides
we consider that as the micro RNA
specifically so I think that's what the
person would be talking about
so from gaijin we have developed this
series of micro RNA easy mini kits and
the micro RNA z96 kit depending on your
your your isolation either from cells or
tissues we also have if you're working
with clinical samples we all especially
with human blood we also have the pax
teen blood micro RNA and tissue micro
RNA kits which can be used for blood
which is stored with the vaccine blood
RNA tube or the tissue containers
respectively and because there are many
protocols have been developed for micro
RNA so you can also isolate using a
supplementary protocol which can be
found out on Titans literature page and
I would really recommend to have a look
at that because there are many user
develop protocols there yeah thank you
great thank you so much I wish a our
next question is do you have a kick for
RNA isolation from any kind of sample
type well that's an interesting question
because I think during the presentation
as I shared with you that every sample
type and every every tissue or we can
categorize them a little bit like we
couldn't call them is equalized tissues
or cell lysates or difficult to lifes
tissues but then you have special needs
for different type of sample types and
that's why there is a range of kits that
have been developed with standardized
protocols behind that so yeah I mean
there's no one for all solution but I
think if you want you just want to do
some you have some easy metallized
tissues or cells and I would say are an
easy class many if you have more
difficult to lyse tissues like rat tail
or or hurt or
something like that or fatty tissues
then I would say not an AZ plus
universal mini should be the solution
for you but at the same time as I said
then you have dedicated kits for plant
or viral or bacterial so you should
always check out these these selection
guides available depending on sample
type yeah thank you have a wonderful
audience today and time for a couple of
more questions there's one is it
possible to isolate RNA from saliva oh
yes definitely I mean you can and I
think it's important especially and this
is becoming bigger and bigger like
especially people who are working in
infectious diseases or for micro
microbiome portfolio so and chitin
recently has acquired a company called
mobile which is which is based in
California in and they have they have
specialized with the with working with
microbiome so if you go on chi-chan comm
you'll find specialized solutions for
working with saliva or soil or hiren or
different type of clinical samples thank
you we have time for one more question
our audience member would like to know
how do I make sure the G DNA is
completely removed from RNA I think
that's that's a good question
so as I as I mentioned that it's an
important we all understand that in
computing genomic DNA removal so it
would be important that you use a
protocol which which all removes the
genomic DNA during the RNA isolation
process itself and that would be either
using a eliminated solution or on column
digestion at the same time you can
always if you are doing very sensitive
application and you think there might be
a chance you can always use additional
rnase free DNA set and then you can use
the DNA set to further and
that should normally give you complete
removal of genomic DNA and and some
people still do during the cDNA
synthesis they use the DNA's which is
also fine which is which is no problem
that doesn't hinder anything it's just
an additional step but yeah you can you
can do that also yeah I'll be shaykh
thank you so much for your informative
presentation and your important research
do you have any closing remarks you'd
like to share with the audience before
we close today no I'm
I think it was very very nice session
and I'm always open for any more
questions when people listen to it
afterwards they can always reach out to
us and I think everyone knows that
Kaizen is a global leader in the and
have been the pioneers of sample
technologies and we keep on improving of
our techniques so yes yeah feel free to
reach out to our technical team or any
one of us if you have any questions
related to your experiment designing I
would say non designing but it during
your protocol selection or if you if you
have any technical questions or related
to RNA yields or queries yeah thank you
thank you again wonderful thank you
again Ali Sheikh for your presentation
I'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor kaya Jen for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
we hope to see you again soon
bye-bye